créé en 1993 l'association vacuasud que
préside désormais José développe la
culture et l'exploitation du vacquois va
quoi Pinpin Saint-Philippe et sa côte
sauvage c'est la Réunion profonde simple
dynamique que Josy nous fait découvrir à
travers une activité artisanale
transmise depuis plusieurs générations
dans ce lieu typique de notre île
alors pour commencer le semis il faut le
peintre
mûr parce qu'il faut attendre quand même
que le papa soit venir pour que les
graines bon bah on a même pas la peine
de semer enfin moi ce que je fais je
laisse le Pinpin comme ça et puis ça
pousse tout seul ça c'est le semis
plus grand plus grand et puis bon ben on
attend quand même ça soit voilà on
attend comme ça
voilà
comment vous commencez le travail avec
le bas quoi c'est à dire que vous faites
ça par étape par étape et puis c'est
l'étape est quand même assez long parce
que depuis
du plan à la cueillette il faut compter
au moins 4 à 5 ans pour commencer à
enlever les feuilles de l'arbre mais et
puis après bon ben il y a quand même
qu'il faut il faut enlever les épines il
faut le fondre il faut le mettre à
sécher et le problème que nous à
s'infiler qu'on rencontre c'est que on
n'a pas beaucoup de soleil et alors il
faut bon ben il faut surveiller
surveiller et puis on peut l'étendre ou
accrocher avec le vent ça se ça sèche
si on a de la place si on a de la place
mais on peut ça pousse facilement le bas
quoi ça peut pousser même sans terre si
on lui met à côté d'une roche c'est tout
nouveau le camp ça pousse tout seul mais
il faut quand même attendre trois quatre
ans c'est une plante comprend on utilise
tout d'accord on utilise depuis la la le
cœur jusqu'à les racines c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les races
alors le les racines le avant
c'est-à-dire que sur le trempé il y
avait un monsieur bon ben il est mort et
on n'a pas pris on aurait dû apprendre à
faire c'est des vannes avec les racines
de Pinpin on faisait les vannes et puis
pour les le qu'on appelle ça au bout de
la racine il y a un D on appelle ça le D
on fait un rafraîchissement mais dans
l'eau pour rafraîchir bon bah le cœur on
fait le choix
et puis après il y a le fruit c'est le
Pinpin et puis on a on fait à la cuisine
on fait le gratin la confiture
les beignets
tout ce que vous trouvez pour la fête
par quoi c'est dans la plante
là il y a un petit chou là
alors ça c'est le shoot par quoi
ça commence à durcir les feuilles on
enlève
on en a les feuilles on continue juste
les bouts alors juste les boules et puis
bon bah après ça ça passe plus de toute
façon quand c'est dur ça passe sur
l'arabe on enlève et puis on continue
jusqu'à la fin et pour un carré il faut
combien de choses comme ça pour
pour une grande famille aux cheveux un
choux de vacances on doit bien manger 3
3 4 personnes enfin je voudrais quoi un
peu plus gros comme celui-là
si on enlève le chou normalement la
plante elle est morte oui mais si on
arrive à le couper une certaine manière
ça repousse ça repousse
si on coupe une certaine hauteur si on
coupe plus bas bon ben elle est bon mais
si on coupe une certaine hauteur on a la
chance de ravoir des
des petites des petites pousses
au niveau des feuilles est-ce que toutes
les feuilles sont bonnes à travailler ou
est-ce qu'il y a un choix est-ce qu'il y
a une maturité au niveau de la maturité
des chats qu'il faut attendre 4 à 5 ans
et puis tous les ans on peut enlever que
10 à 20 feuilles trois fois dans l'année
pas plus parce qu'il faut pas tout
enlever parce que si vous enlevez toute
le les feuilles bon ben la plante elle
va elle poussera pas normalement mais
sinon il faut attendre et puis bon il y
a des feuilles il y a des feuilles que
c'est bon il y a des feuilles qu'il faut
il faut trier
faut toujours faire le tour de la place
la cueillette c'est pas trop le jour
la cueillette c'est pas tous les jours à
Saint-Philippe si les femmes je pars si
le lundi il y a du soleil mais ils en
profite
c'est le cœur c'est pour avoir quoi plus
blanc et puis bon ben et après des
autres feuilles c'est
les grandes feuilles qui sont
et je sais pas si vous avez remarqué que
là on a un rapport
c'est naturel très joli alors nous aussi
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut pas oublier
de faire c'est qu'on va quoi il est en
train de sécher c'est le retourner pour
que ça sèche pas du même toute l'humain
côté faut le tourner alors il faut il
faut surveiller
combien de temps pour réaliser un objet
on prendra un exemple de temps ont une
tente
je pense qu'il doit falloir quand même
au moins deux à trois heures après que
le vieux
est déjà prête à travailler oui parce
que toute façon on peut pas vraiment
calculer du temps parce que quand on
prépare on prépare que pas pour une
tente d'accord on prépare une botte de
bottes trois bottes et puis bon bah dans
la semaine on tient oublié on va faire
une tente mais on a vraiment pas le le
calcul en tête pour dire que vraiment
pour la tante on a mis 3 4 et qui vous a
appris à travailler ses objets à
perfectionner à faire évoluer le va quoi
apprendre à travailler peut-être nos
parents alors parents parce que c'est
quand même un travail qui date pas de
d'aujourd'hui mais dire le apprendre à
mieux travailler et puis à chercher à
faire autre chose c'est c'est de la
femme elle-même elle cherche à si on
voit un sac je sais pas moi un sac qui
est bien on voit un sac à dos tiens on
dit tiens tout de suite pourquoi pas on
va pourquoi ne pas faire on va quoi et
puis bon ben les idées c'est comme ça on
tend beaucoup au tourisme c'est sûr
parce qu'on quand même pas mal de notre
local et bien placé déjà bien situé et
puis on est on a quand même pas mal de
passages les gens qui viennent en
vacances il y a les rayonnais qui
partent en vacances ils cherchent
toujours un petit cadeau à faire plaisir
et puis bon ben on passe à un autre
local et puis c'est à dire qu'il y en a
quand même pas mal aussi sur les routes
il y a que quand à saint-philie il y a
quand même pas que notre local il y en a
plusieurs
on peut trouver facilement chez une
artisane ou
alors voilà on parlait du cœur de faire
quoi sécher un peu plus blanc alors
c'est c'est ça c'est un peu plus clair
vous avez quoi marron on avait des
feuilles mortes qu'on prend sur le
récolte sur le sous le pied et voilà le
vaquois gris alors c'est des petites
taches
mais c'est naturel
le pays d'accueil
des entreprises enfin ça dépend on a
quand même des grosses commandes aussi à
travailler la nuit c'est sûr souvent la
nuit
respecter les commandes et puis on peut
pas faire une grosse provision de
vacquois alors il faut le voir quoi il
faut travailler préparer mes travailler
pas le stocker parce que l'humidité a
Saint Philippe on a de un temps quand
même assez humide et puis ça
est-ce que vous avez des enfants
je pense que toutes les femmes ont des
enfants toutes les femmes ont des
enfants mais la plupart des enfants des
enfants ils ne sont pas intéressés
nous on était intéressé nous dans notre
temps enfin on était intéressé on
n'avait pas le choix aussi dans notre
dans le temps nous on était jeune on a
des plats vraiment
le par quoi était pas reconnu comme
maintenant mais
des enfants des artisanes je vois pas il
y en a pas beaucoup
de continuer et se déplace pas est-ce
que vous croyez que
c'est un travail d'avenir est-ce que
c'est un travail d'avenir c'est pas un
travail d'avenir parce qu'on devient pas
riche avec le vacua mais c'est un plus
pour les femmes surtout de Saint
Philippe qu'on est loin quand même de
des grandes villes et puis
les femmes bon ben depuis petites qui
sont commencé à travailler pour eux
c'est un passe-temps un plaisir plus
tard vous croyez que ça va se développer
et que ça pourrait être un métier déjà
pour les jeunes donc je ne puissent déjà
reprendre la relève et puis
il y a tellement de choses à faire avec
le va quoi que ce serait vraiment
dommage moi je trouve que la Maison de
la Presse serait plus déjà pour
Saint-Philippe et puis pour montrer
notre savoir-faire